what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with another episode of our
beyond omega level series which we
forgot to do on friday so we're doing it
today and then we're doing another one
on friday so we're doing two in one week
to get us back on schedule and we have a
viewer suggestion from r evan w who said
that since we had done an episode on
zeus we needed to do one on nyx the
goddess of darkness so that's what we're
going to do here today so nyx was
created by al ewing jim zub mark wade
and joshua james shaw and first appeared
in avengers no road home in 2019. so
she's a relatively new character and
we've only seen her within the no road
home miniseries that was released weekly
in early 2019. but the series basically
opened with a character known as voyager
or vonnie gast who was a character that
was introduced in late 2018 as a
supposed lost avenger named valerie
vector who had been around since the
group's founding and had just everybody
just forgot about her to be quite honest
but as it turns out she was actually the
daughter of the grand master that was
placed on earth as his agent and it
implanted false memories in people's
minds to make it seem like she was this
famous superhero that had been forgotten
now eventually she turns on her father
and becomes an ally of the avengers and
as the no-road home mini-series begins
she's basically going around assembling
a team of avengers to deal with a threat
that's causing the whole world to go
dark so voyager rounds up a few avengers
for her team including hawkeye scarlet
witch vision spectrum and hulk before
she finally finds hercules and tells him
that his home mount olympus has been
attacked by this threat now voyager uses
her teleportation powers to open a
portal to olympus and hercules finds
most of the greek gods have basically
been slaughtered except for her sister
athena who is clinging to life and so
she tells hercules that the carnage he
sees is the work of the queen of the
night whose name he's not allowed to
utter now scarlet witch then explains
that according to greek myth the goddess
of the night is called nix which proves
to be a mistake not because the
information is incorrect but because
immediately after saying her name she
shows up and places her hand through
wanda's head which i always thought was
a really weird circumstance because you
would think that hercules would know
greek mythology better than wanda would
but we ultimately end up seeing a
flashback to what happened on mount
olympus which is that nyx had shown up
and talked about how mad she is that
zeus had locked her away and mocks the
greek gods because nobody worships them
anymore before she and her minions just
start wrecking the whole place now we
also learned that mix was freed from her
imprisonment when the earth was briefly
moved away from the sun during a game
between the grand master and the
challenger which voyager was also a part
of furthermore we learned that when he
imprisoned her zeus took three night
shards from nick's soul which is just
wild now while being tortured zeus
reveals that he gave one of the shards
to an ally in a place of knowledge one
to an enemy in a place of dreams and
place one in a far-off paradise now
after getting this information nyx
effortlessly snaps zeus's neck killing
him instantly and so when we consider
that zeus himself is beyond omega level
it stands to reason that if nyx is able
to kill him without breaking a sweat
that she would also be pretty far beyond
this guy now nyx then states to her
minions that with the gods out of the
way her plan is to wipe the universe
clean and start a new one which makes
sense right the greek gods are the ones
standing between just the end of all
things total oblivion but of course this
will require her to regain the shards
that zeus had hidden but what is
mind-blowing about this is that without
the shards nyx is at her weakest so she
was able to take out all the gods of
olympus at a mere fraction of her full
power and is also able to withstand a
combined attack from the avengers and
voyager without being significantly
harmed now it's at this point that nyx's
true origin was revealed and we learned
that she existed before there was light
and when more and more light came into
existence because of zeus it became
clear that the two of them could not
coexist now zeus then builds mount
olympus which becomes an immense source
of light chipping away at the darkness
and therefore at nyx's power now once
humans were given fire there was even
more light and nyx was weakened even
further and so as the olympians were
worshipped by humans nyx became angrier
and vowed to exact revenge on the gods
now when the inevitable fight between
nicks and the gods occurred the gods
banded together to defeat her and zeus
took the shards of her soul and
imprisoned her in darkness where she
grew angrier and angrier now when the
earth leaves the orbit of the sun and
nyx is ultimately freed she causes
darkness to fall over every light source
not only on earth but in the entire
universe now eventually nyx is able to
acquire two of three shards containing
her soul and makes her way to a planet
called euphoria which had been created
by the silver surfer and his companion
dawn greenwood to be inhabited by the
citizens of another planet which had
been destroyed now euphoria is a
sentient planet and had been given the
final shard by zeus and so a battle
raged between nyx and the avengers and
during this fight euphoria offered the
shard to nix willingly which returned
her to full power now with her godhood
restored nyx was able to see the center
of all reality the birthplace of all
that was all that is and all that ever
will be which really sounds like a bread
heart promo and the place from which she
will remake the universe a house in long
island new york
now it turns out the house is actually
the house of ideas which is the point
from which all marvel stories originate
and the house of ideas those you guys
who don't know is a nickname for marvel
comics that they actually had back in
the 60s and 70s when marvel was
revolutionizing superhero comics unlike
now so to incorporate it into an actual
story is pretty meta as is the way that
nyx is eventually defeated so before nyx
can rebuild the entire multiverse in her
image vision is able to breach the house
of ideas through a sliver of light that
remained as the door closed now once
inside he has a conversation with nyx
and explains that a universe cannot be
created out of darkness but requires
light because the imagination needed to
create a universe is synonymous with
life now vision then takes the form of
the human torch and burns next to ashes
but she proclaims that she will not be
gone forever and there will always be
darkness but up to this point that's all
we've seen of nyx although it is
possible she may return somewhere down
the road as far as her powers go
basically she can control darkness she
can summon darkness she can create
constructs made of shadow to basically
do her bidding and she can become a
shadow herself making herself intangible
she also has immense super human
physical attributes and can teleport
through time and space at will and while
we have only seen her in one series the
fact that she wiped out a pantheon of
gods while at her weakest without
breaking a sweat would be enough to call
her omega level but she was on the verge
of recreating reality and likely would
have succeeded if the writers hadn't
been set on making some sort of meta
commentary on imagination in life but
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace